a décié Demar la PE Noël il n aura pas
de traditionn guland rou et ver de
boules doré de traîneau ou même de père
Noël pour rendre Noël plus inclusif et
multicultur multiculturel la ville a
décidé d'opter pour le thème du voyage
en hiver et proposera donc des
décorations aux couleur pastel et une
mer Noël en
jogging on en peut plus en fait on peut
plus on peut plus on a marre on peut
plus on a en tout cas d'entendre g
ver je demande juste un truc défoncez-le
défoncez-le j'ai rien dit encore mainant
on sait très bien ce que tu vas dire on
me défonce avant que je
par je pense que maintenant c'est ce
qu'on va faire ouis au moins ça nous
évitera de t'écouter alors est-ce une
bonne idée êtes-vous choqué par cette
décision s'il vous plaît je vis les oui
non d'abord voir choqué oui Cho non
alors oui il a plus deux questions dans
la question êtes-vous choqué par cette
décision oui oui bon ah bah très bien
regardez non mais regardez-moi mais
arrête regardez-moi loser loser tu vas
tu vas voir le sondage tu vas le sondage
s'il vous plaît j'aimerais qu'on bah
vous influencez peut-être un peu les
gens là NONAH toi tuas Jama influencé
personne en tout cas en tout cas les
gens n'ont pas besoin de moi pour savoir
que c'est une énorme connerie et
j'attends d'entendre les arguments de
Gilles Verdez le génie des génies hein
bien entendu je sais pas comment elle
fait ta meuf je l'adore ta meuf en plus
je sais pas comment elle fait s'est
cassé quoi elle s'est cassée mais non
elle est là encore ave elle est revenue
ah d'accord elle est
revenue c'est ça s'en va ça revient elle
est revenu il est con à Nant des visages
inconnus remplacent celui du Père Noël
des sculptures lumineuses à la place des
décorations de Noël classique un choix
de la ville qui crée l'incompréhension
de certains habitants ça m'aurait fait
plaisir de pouvoir me promener avec mes
enfants voir les décorations de Noël
toutes ces animations qu'on a connu
quand on était enfant dans ce programme
d'illumination baptisé le voyage en
hiver l'une des artistes propose
d'incarneret Noël avec la sculpture
d'une petite Maman Noël petite Maman
Noël porte un jog avec des chaussettes
de
Noël alors c'est non mais Géraldine s'il
te plaît est-ce qu'on d'abord oui oui
oui oui on le laisse parler d' ou sorte
de feu d'artifice de bêtis ouaisier mais
lui s rigoler
lui c'est sympathique quand
même vouses
sy voulez que je donne mes arguments
vas-y là vous venez critiquer la M de
Paris maintenant vous allez vous taper
la mer de N que pour vous les maires
n'ont aucun sens alors que je vous
signale que si fait ça c'est pour à tout
le monde pas à vous bien
entend qui comment si si n es surpuplé
tu vas y aller de jours ils vont tous
bar si j'habitais Nant je me réjouirais
d'aller à ces festivités enfin un Noël
multiculturel enfin Noël réconcilié
enfin Noël pour tous c'est pour
ça laiss
finir catholique pour les catholiques on
entre dans un Noël pour toutes les
confessions pourquoi vous mettez oui
vous êtes fou mais vous êtes
complètement malade mais quoi Mo tu
lèves la main mais toi tu devrais être
de mon côté tu es jeune tu es pas encore
débile comme les autres mais c'est
incroyable mais c'est
incroyableoind t idée sur un truc enfin
le drapeau de Noël mais qu'est-ce que tu
as enfin le drapeau de Noël pour tous
regardez ces vitrines magnifies mais
excuse-moi tu es sérieux là mais oui
mais bien sûr que mais pour alors
excusez-moi la mère de Nant elle a été
élue comme d'autres mèr pourquoi elle
aurait fait ça mais c'est pas dans son
progam a y a des elle a pas dit dans son
programme électoral je vais
faire s devenu un énorme non mais tous
tous les maires sont débiles alors tous
les Mair sont n'importe quoi arrête je
vais te dire le problème qu' a c'est les
mè ils savent plus quoi faire pour faire
parler d'ux donc ils font souvent des
trucs pour ils vont dire il ça va faire
parler depuis quand le Père Noël depuis
quand le Père Noël depuis quand les
guirlandes depuis quand le sapin divise
les gens c'est païen c'est païen c'est
pas religieux on est dans at est
dansre pe
imporigionè less les vitrines Noël avec
les cleursvec les sain les pèr Noël en
quoi c'est plus inclusive d'avoir une
mère Noël en jogging que d'avoir un père
Noël attendsends y a jeanmichelich'
plaî tout le monde est pour la paix
entre les religions et cetera voilà
c'est très beau on est tous d'accord
sauf que là on excuse-moi le dire de
rappelez on est quand même en terre
chrétienne Noël c'est important pour les
Français et donc célébrer Noël c'est
quelque chose qui nous tient à cœur dé
peut-être alors je ne savais pas je
pourrais te l'offrir aujourd'hui g Cyril
si vous pourraz offrir ça à Gill je lui
offrir un petit cadeau de Noël avant
l'heure et là je pensais pas pouvoir le
sortir aujourd'hui offrezlii offrezli
offrezli ouvrezle ouvrezle ouvrez-le non
cy ouvrez-le ouvrez-le ouvrezle ouvrezle
c'est c'est pour toi cadeau ça m'a coûté
de l'argent je te le dis
hein une paire de couillille je t'ai
acheté une paire de couille parce vraim
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ou tu la mettre
en la mettre pend POS sur la
table çatrade elle est toujours dans le
sens du vent de ceux qui sont toujours
Pascal de la tu pas ça la change le
BFM je dire que là tiens B tiens je te
donne ton cadeau cadeau on va te la
mettre en pendentif sur la table PL sur
table c'est
pas quce que qu'est-ce que tu lui
réponds voulez que je réponde à ça non
mais ch franchement quel est le rapport
quel est le rapport tu mes convictions
contre vous mais c'est vous qui avez
tort mais non parce que toi tu penses tu
réfléchis toujours alors-ce faut dire
pas avoir d'EMDE ah je dire que c'est
bienê
Malis je dans sens ris c'est ce que tu
fais tout le monde est contre
moi mettez oui pour plaire à tout le
monde dire un truc là juste je vais
défendre de petit second en tout cas
c'est pas le bon cadeau parce que en
vrai quand Mme il est toujour cont tout
ouais non mais la seule personne qui va
dans son sens à chaque fois tu
l'attaques c'est qui bah c'est moi à
chaque fois je vais dans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cade voilà vous avec un cadeau oui non
mais non mais laissons Mo parler si
mooun va dans mon sens on peut l'écouter
alors là en l'occurrence si j'ai alors
si j'ai mis oui c'est parce que
d'habitude dans T sens et c'est ce que
j'ai dit d'ailleurs à la pub je disais
justement à Cyril je trouve que je vais
souvent dans le même sens que Gill parce
que je suis assez d'accord avec lui mais
là là-dessus je trouve que Noël c'est
quand même multiculturel et je trouve
que il y a pas de religion dans des
boules et des guirlandes et un sapin
enfin je comprends quandme mais
qu'est-ce qui vous choque
là que paradoxalement c'est
contreproductif parce que ça monte les
gens les uns contre les autres au ça
vous monre vous vous êtes les forces de
réaction s' vous PL si vous nous
rejoignez les chéris le Père Noël
remplacé par une mère Noël en jogging
pas de sapin pas de guirlande êtes-vous
choqué par le Noël W de la ville de
Nantes Géraldine maill non mais c'est
une bêtise wiste dans toute sa
splendeur ouais en fait je trouve que
c'est une bêtise donc wist dans toute sa
splendeur en fait pour moi le wisme en
fait c'est une nouvelle dictature c'està
dire que ça divise ça exclut et ça
stigmatise donc toi tu te veux moderne
et progressiste alors en faisant ça tu
sens la naftaline en fait ça n'a aucun
sens de faire ça pourquoi veux-tu
absolument R notre tradition et notre
culture en quoi c'est une avancée
dis-moi juste pourquoi c'est quoi le
cheminement intellectuel qui fait que
nul part ailleurs on renie nos
traditions et culture et nous dans nos
démocraties occidentales on veut
absolument renier nos traditions et nos
culture pourquoi c'est quoi le
cheminement je veux inclure
contrairement à vous qui divisez jeux
incl problèm pas
insupportable a pas puisque c'est vous
qui CR problè voinusion c'est
l'exclusion réalité tu VO pas au nom du
c'est insupportable pour moi Noël c'est
un père Noël un sapin des guland c'est
pas des gargouilles éclaté au sol et
mère Noë en joging c'est n'importe quoi
ça même Noël le seul moment on se
rassemble en famille on est on est tous
ensemble les bobo veent nous les G
commeulent
faire petits enfantsmatiattend Noël avec
impatience Paris
non mais tu as déjà end c'est c'est pour
c'est pour tout le monde déjà Noë
Noël en dehors de la religion en dehors
de ceux qui fêtent un Noël chrétien le
Noël moi par exemple je ne suis pas de
religion catholique mais pour moi Noël
c'est l'esprit de Noël c'est le sapin
c'est et et ça me fait plaisir au même
titre que j'imagine des catholiques ou
des musulmans enfin pour moi il y a pas
de il y a pas de fion mais vous êtes
adorable mais vous êtes la vieille
France et là c'est la France qui
progresse c'est ça VI France c'est toi
mais non mais c'est la France qui
progresse mais vous vous rendez pas
pourquoi il aime se flagé pourquoi il
aime se flagé G inclure tout le mond mon
tu veux que je te monte le sondage avant
que tu continues à parler hein c'est
peut-être pas la peine mais si vous
voulez si ça vous fait plaisir voilà
quel loser mais les gens les gens qui
pensent ça en fait sont en quelque sorte
j'accuse pas Gill mais c'est un peu des
fouteurs de merde on est dans un
contexte d'énorme tension et vous
pointez du bois du doigt des non des non
sujets qui n'existent pas et et et et
vous montez les gens les uns contre les
autres en appuyant sur le fait que c'est
fête religieuse et pas d'utre
religieuse celui qui veut pas faire Noël
il fait pas Noël on force pas les gens à
faire non mant ces gens-là qui qui qui
mettent ça en place j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont jamais été enfants et c'est
comme les mères qu'enlèvent les sapins
moi les mères qu' enlèvent les sapins je
vais pas les je les emmerde moi les ça
c'est c'est pas bien d'enlever les
sapins laisser les sapins laisser les
guirlandes laisseer la fête laisser
l'esprit de Noël pour les gens qui
veulent faire Noël parce que c'est c'est
la tradition de ce pays-là vous voulez
pas faire Noël vous faites pas Noël mais
on n' pas à mettre une une mère Noël sur
une balançoire et comme il dit éclater
au soleil ça tu veux le faire fais-le
toute l'année fais-le le 18 18 mars si
tu veux faire Noël 18 mars tu crois
vraent que c no tu pens que ça c'est
inclus fa pas de photos avec
elle tu crois qu'il y aura moins de
sexisme moins de violence tu penses que
le soir de Noël parce qu'il y a une mère
Noël comme ça il y aura moins de femmes
battues il y aura c'est quoi c'est quoi
le truc en fait dans c'est inclure dans
Noël tout le monde toutes les
confessions religieuses NOTAM c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est aussi simple
que
ça dis la vérité parce qu'il y a plein
de gens qui me posent la question VI de
dire là non mais il y a ple de gens qui
me posent question qui me disent est-ce
que Gilles est vraiment sérieux ou
est-ce que tu as fait ça pour être à
contrecourant mais il est
sérieux nonom pour me faire défoncer par
vous tous par les gens sur les réseaux
soute par vos amis par le sondage et par
plaisir non mais les gens qui vous
écrivent là qui vous
demand oui je sais par plaisir je vais
mettre nom pour prendre des bffes de
partout avec ce qu'il a dit là faut
inclure toutes toutes les traditions non
NONAH quand les juifs ils font qui pour
moi je les laisse
amam quand c'est Noël c'est toutonde
pourquoi on vit pas ensemble avec les
fes de
Ch pèreèv le père noëlèv les
SAP moi tu me punis tu m'enlève mon père
Noël et tu m'enlèves mon
SAP P surt non mais g pourquoi on peut
revoir la photo de la Mère Noël voilà
en permet de célébrer Noël avec toutes
les religions mais c'est parce que vous
retirez l'aspect purement religieux de
Noël c'est
ça mais
globalement c'est beaucoup plus inclusif
que Père Noël c'est marrant parce que
c'est une belle initiative et vous
arrivez à la gâer à la
ridiculisertive c'est quand tu arrêteras
avec tes
copains B là vos B
là vasy au viux
campeur viampur va acheter des aigles
vasy g en fait vous pensez sérieusement
moi j'ai une question pour vous ça fait
10 plus 10 ans qu'on se connaît vous
pensez sérieusement que je vais mettre
non en pensant oui parce que là je me
suis dit peut-être qu' veut nous
taquiner on essaie de te
sauveress de te sauver mon parce queim
bien quandme j'ai besoin de personne
pour rester dans mes convictions même si
elles sont ultra
minoritaires pas marre de toujours
perdre non mais je perds pas j'affirme
mes conviction et encore une fois la mre
de Nant c'est pas n'importe qui quoi
elle a été élue par les Nant arrêtez si
elle fait ça c'est
parid mais c'est quoi le projet c'est
quoi le résultat inclure tout le monde
mais tu ça fait 10 fois que je
dis en fait tu
t'arrêtes formable c'estinclusion c'est
l'inclusion tu vois pas que c'est
exactement le contraire c'est
l'exclusion c'est la culture de
l'effacement c'est la culture de la
h tradition la honte de notre histoire
et là c'est quoi le projet en
fait
Inc g g git un sur G ver modernité non
mais la modernité frère non mais
regarde-moi ça mais s rigol on dira mais
le gars on dirait qu'il dans la Gata
Christi c'est la modernité dirait
petertin et puis surtout puisque tu veux
inclure tout le mondeticule
vas-y si tu veux inclure tout le monde
tu veux tu veux supprimer Noël j'imagine
que tu veux supprimer aussi Laï qui pour
et cetera on supprime tout supprimer Noë
c'est no mais dingue ou
quoi
unëet alors c'est
Nau pour défendre les minorités
explique-moi quel est le projet là qui a
un rapport avec la culture des minorités
pour tous un Noë pour tous multiculturel
multiconfessionnelon le nouveau Ramadan
n pour c'est
quo une religion chrétienne je comprends
pas en
quoi inclusif on commence par effacer
les gens comm sentir incl dans le Kipour
ou dans le ramadan dis-moi ça va être
quoi alors maintenant le nouveau code et
tout ça j'en sais rien mais là parle des
décorations de Noël arrêé je vous parle
des décorations de Noël et je trouve ça
formidable voà ok d'accord qu'est-ce que
vous voulez je voulais juste savoir les
décorations dans la rue moi je les
trouve vraiment pas festive de Noël et
cetera mais par contre la Mère Noël je
vois pas ce qu'il y a de dérangeant
parce que c'est le Père Noël c'est tout
oui
joging le père Nol il j bien c'est une
pauvre dame sur une balançoire arr le
Père Noël il est habé mais le père Noël
il est habillé pareil mais non le Père
Noël il est pas
habillé c'est un homme il a une barbe a
pas de barbe pas de ça va pas mais la
Mère Noël mais la Mère Noël ça fait des
années que il a le Père Noël la Mère
Noël je vois pas ce que en quoi ça
dérange qu'il y ait la Mère Noël avant
le Père Noël mais le problème c'est pas
la Mère Noël le problème c'est Gill qui
nous dit que ça ça permet de d'avoir
toutes les Rion sur mais pourquoi en
fait cette image là se comme ça elle me
choque pas ah ouais non mais on s'en
fout surtout en fait c'est chaussette le
Père Noël il est pareil hein mais non il
a une Barant que je l'ai pas
vu
exprès est dans une culture on est dans
une culture de tradition et là en fait
ce qu'on veut nous montrer c'est la
honte voilà on a honte de nos traditions
donc on veut les cacher on veut les
modifier mais c'est la culture de
l'effacement c'est arrête Gill Verdez on
est en France respecte les valeurs tu
crois que dans d'autres pays il changent
leur culture David Antonios blanc bravo
David tiens et si tu veux il y a auun P
continue à l ah oui
tous pourquoi pourquoi Gill tu veux t de
grosses conneries ce n'est justement pas
multiculturel c'est Noël qui est
multiculturel
connard conard connard av av pas écrit
ça fait plaisir quand même ça fait
plaisir non mais après c'est bien que je
dis ça parce que j'imagine qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui pensent aussi
ça non mais ça correspond à un courant
aujourd'hui
mais globalement la présidentielle
globalement c'est gauche contre droite à
N d'ailleurs toute la droite s'élève
contre ça et toute la
gauch tu vois le problème tu vois le
problème là tu viens de dire exactement
le problème tu as politisé un truc qui n
pas pas pour le coup c'est transpartisan
c'est pas une histoire de droite ou de
gauche c'est transpartisant c'est une
histoire est-ce qu'on a envie avec ses
enfants d' dans une forme de tradition
on envoie des lettres au Père Noël à
Livourne et père avec le secrétariat du
Père Noël répond et puis dans une sorte
mais la France avance sans vous tant pis
c'est dommage voilà c'est tout tu veras
de sapin vendu et tu verra si la France
elle avance sa que toi qui adore toi qui
adore c'est goen royal et c'est goen
royal qui adore les traditions je suis
sûr qu'elle elle est contre par exemple
cette mesureêtre et donc toi qui
aimerait bien voter pour elle et ben en
fait tu vois tu vois que là encore tu es
dans une impasse est quoi le maire de
Nant ça je crois qu'elle PS non Johann
Roland je crois je suis pas sûr ah ouais
B on peut regarder je pense merci c'est
c'est e les mecs Johanna Roland un B ah
bah tu vois si on avait mis la photo
avant PS
PS très bien notre ville de Nantes est
moche sans toutes ses lumières de Noël
c'est pas clair c'est moche c'est du
n'importe quoi elle a pas elle aé sur
Gil verd non non non maisattend
j'attends mais c'est c'est vrai c'est
c'est quelqu'un de Nant c'est une copine
qui travaille à Nant qui habite à Nant
ah il est
ili
n'importe quoi on a pas pas savoir
desfussés visibleement on pas Dr de
connaîre des gens savoir desfussés non
pas j'en aurais plus d'info non ouais tu
as raison tuas fous dans la merde
qu'est-ce qui se passe Jacques Cardo non
non rien qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y a
quelqu'un qui t'écrit de N to toi aussi
tuas une meuf à n La dig la dig non il
c'est pas j'ai plein de réponses sur
Nant mais c'est pareil disent bah ils
disent tous que c'est complètement
grotesque ce que tu dis n'importe quoi
tu regardes sur Twitter tu as pas des
réponses à
toi
balancé merci Mo bravo elle l' balancé
les masques tombent merci
Mo des messes plein de fois pour le foot
plein de fois dernière fois la vérité la
dernière fois que je suis all à N ça
fait longtemps a 4 5 ans ouais plus non
pourqui plus vous connaissez ma vie 4
ans je suis allé à je suis désolé fait
plus de 5 ans mat non j' j'allis non non
non j'allais souvent à pornicher avec ma
fille on passit par ça fait pas plus de
5 ans bah non ça doit faire 5 suis allé
à pornich avec ma fille la dernière fois
je passis par N plus de 5 an bah il
c'est mieux que toi non quand même non
je pense pas non fait plus de 5 an av
vous j'aim bien Nant j'aime bien Nant
vous aussi pour le on va on va
accueillir un ami à gillverd Jean
[Rires]
men ça va faire un progressiste de plus
autour de la table une bonne soirée pour
je dis cauchemar pour oh là là quelqu'un
a quelque chose à dire à Gill verd avant
de l
tiens euh bah il est où l'oseille
j'avais préparé un petit peoseille pour
toi euh non mais c'est vrai bon c'est
pas grave on va me le ramener
Jean-Michel il a un cadeau ouais non non
tuas un
cadeau non non non non non c'est
l'esprit de no joie d'offrir plaisir de
recevoir pas beso ton cadeau on a pas
besoin on on a jamais été à la pisine
ensemble donc il y a pas de place pour
ça chez moi
W e monsieur voilà en toute modestie
hein et euh alors ça va très
bien oh ça va c'est pasom là e qu'est-ce
que tu penses de Noël là cette histoire
là adante là qu'ils enlèvent le Père
Noël tout ça juste avant qu'on parle de
ton affaire Gilles Verdez il faut qu'il
aille plus loin parce que le Noël n'est
pas assez inclusif là la Mère Noël n'est
pas
racisée donc c'est c'est c'est c'est un
Noël raciste en fait tu sais où tu peux
te la mettre ta cagnotte al onum on
parlera de la cannotte après c'est non
mais non mais F non mais c'est-à-dire
que si tu si on met le doigt dans cet
engrenage là j'ai c'était c'était une
boutade évidemment mais si on met le
doigt dans une dans cet engrelage là on
na jamais satisfait à tout le monde si
tu transformes le Père Noël en mère Noël
mais la Mère Noël si elle reste blanche
tu auras toujours des minorités qui
diront bah je suis pas représenté et ca
et cetera et et ou alors effectivement
des minorités LGBT et Cera qui seront
qui seront pas représentés dans cette
dans dans ce Père Noël là ou dans cette
Mère Noël là donc tu t'arrêtes où en
fait tu vas créer plusieurs pèr Noël
pour les toutes les catégories les mini
catégories les sous-catégories
précisément le le la fête de Noël dans
ce qu' est traditionnellement c'est la
clé de voûte qui permet de rassembler
tout le monde et se de se reconnaître
dans C se emblème